[Musik]
wir haben hier 80 alte obstbäume stehen
auch viele junge obstbäume und tier
wachsen die äpfel für unser winter apfel
das sind ganz viele verschiedene alte
sorten aber da hinten schaut heute als
bäume die schon über 120 jahre alt sind
und das ist dann nicht nur ein lieferant
für unsere äpfel sondern auch ein
wahnsinnig wertvoller lebensraum für
ganz viele verschiedene tier und
pflanzenarten
[Musik]
nachdem dann die äpfel beendet wurden da
fahren wir das mit unseren traktoren
also das heißt auch wirklich dass die
wege kurz sind zur kelterei in flieden
und dort werden die äpfel
weiterverarbeitet und wir dann unser
winter apfel auch fertig angemischt
[Musik]
unser wenn der weihnachtsbaum von hund
eigentlich auf drei haupt tage
um den wunsch zu hause zubereiten nimmt
man liter wasser hinein lässt das ein
wenig aufkochen und eben den
zimtgeschmack herauszubekommen sich dann
abgesagt hinzu und die hauptzutat oder
geheime zutat von unseres der
holunderblütensirup da kommen dann so
circa 180 milliliter auf 1 liter noch
hinzu verliert das lässt das waren
werden auf ca 75 grad und hat dann ein
wunderbar leckerem wunsch seit einiger
zeit ist der jinja sehr im trend und
unser winter ab vielleicht nimmt sich
besonders dazu mit gin zu erweitern was
auch ein besonderes geschmackserlebnis
ist
von den acht landwirten der beerenobst
gemeinschaft sind vier bio bauern dh
dass wir wirklich nach biologischen
richtlinien arbeiten zum beispiel auf
dieser wiese hier wird gar nichts
gespritzt und wir haben eine wahnsinnige
vielfalt an verschiedenen äpfeln es gibt
bei uns in der region ungefähr 400
apfelsorten insgesamt weltweit gibt es
2000 apfelsorten man kann wirklich sagen
diese streuobstwiesen das sind die
kleinen regenwälder deutschlands und in
dem man solche produkte von hier
konsumiert schützt man diesen lebensraum
[Musik]